Kendall she's just she's so interesting
and she's so sweet and kind-hearted and
she surprises me every day bachelor in
paradise alums Joe Amelie and Kendall
long have called it quits the former
couple who first met on the fifth season
of the hit ABC reality show in 2018
Joe's smile is just like I just like
hugging announced in a statement to
bachelor nation on Wednesday that they
have mutually decided to go their
separate ways according to their
statement Joe will be moving back to
Chicago and Kendall is staying in her
hometown Los Angeles quote our family
and friends have always been an
extremely important element to who we
are as people we can't imagine
continuing our lives without them closer
especially when thinking of starting a
family of our own one day
the two added that they respect each
other's decision and have a great deal
of love for each other it's not the
first time the couple has parted ways
they initially split while filming
paradise I have no idea why I didn't
chase him but they got back together
when Kendall went to Chicago after
filming wrapped I'm very happy about it
yeah she's an amazing person and you
know it's new it's fun Joe moved to LA
to compete on season 27 of Dancing with
the Stars in 2018 grocery store Joe on
Dancing with the Stars gonna be great to
do this a bit I'm actually having a
panic attack right now if you can't
that's great to go really well super
excited and Kendall was right there to
cheer him on I can't bring Kendall in
just because she's such a good dancer
she'll really embarrass me but we danced
on our own time you know what I mean in
April the two took another big step you
guys moved in together we did West
Hollywood
yeah we've been living together since
literally we sent home and in December
they adopted a dog together when et
caught up with the former lovebirds in
November they said they had talked
wedding bells either of us are scared of
it no and I think it could happen
I could see it happening in somewhat the
near future
I don't but any jewelry company wants to
reach everyone - they even talked about
how they planned to raise their kids in
the future have you talked about kids
it's funny because it's funny because we
talk about like different ways we would
raise kids well yeah we're very when it
comes to that word yeah I would be more
of a disciplinary I guess you could say
like I do believe I do believe well I I
do I do believe it a little bit of that
hard love like more of that tough love
kind of like not everything you do is
perfect I don't believe in spoiling your
kid
[Music]